you're about to meet the spider
equivalent of a stealthy jungle cat this
Virginian specimen is the jumping spider
and it packs a ton of stalking pouncing
killing firepower in its tiny body
here's the victim this be the jumping
spider locks onto the prey and begins
the remarkably sophisticated ritual of
capture the jumping spider contracted me
because of its eight eyes including
these on the back of his head
no matter where the bee is it's on the
jumping spiders radar screen
the spider can't move its eyes so it
moves its body to see two huge front
eyes track the kill even if the eyes
can't move the retinas inside the eyes
can see that play of light and darkness
is the spider looking around
the B has a huge mobility advantage but
the spider is craftier now if this were
a slasher film the audience would be
screaming look out behind you
but the B is oblivious the spider gets
into pounce position it can leap 50
times its body length even though it has
no special muscles
the pounce has to be perfect in every
way
distance timing everything
gotcha
the stakes in this battle couldn't be
higher even the slightest false move by
the spider and the bee will administer a
crippling possibly even a deadly state
how'd you like to stare into these eyes
with your life on the line too huh yikes
the spider got the jump on the bee and
now the bee is one honey of a prize for
the victorious spider